Zinco para resfriado não é todo dia o
ano todo, é estratégia curta. Uma
metaanálise publicada no JRSM Open por
Hari Remilá analisou sete ensaios
clínicos randomizados com 575
participantes e chegou a um número que
deveria estar na caixa de todo o kit de
inverno. Doses diárias acima de 75 mg de
zinco alimentar reduziram a duração do
resfriado em 33%.
E quando os pesquisadores fizeram uma
análise de dados individuais de
pacientes que foi publicada no British
Journal of Clinical Pharmacology, o
resultado foi ainda mais impressionante.
No quinto dia de tratamento, 70% das
pessoas que tomaram pastilhas de zinco
já tinham se recuperado contra apenas
27% do grupo placebo. Mas calma, porque
não é qualquer zinco que funciona, não é
qualquer dose que funciona e
principalmente não é em qualquer momento
que funciona. E é exatamente isso que
diferencia quem usa zinco, o direito de
quem só desperdiça dinheiro na farmácia.
Deixa explicar como é que o zinco atua
no resfriado. Os rinovírus, que são
aqueles principais causadores do
resfriado comum, eles precisam se ligar
a receptores específicos nas células da
mucosa nasal para iniciar a infecção. Os
íons de zinco têm a capacidade de
interferir nessa ligação. Além disso, o
zinco inibe a replicação viral e modula
a resposta inflamatória. Então, na
prática, ele funciona como uma barreira
química que dificulta a vida do vírus
nas suas vias aéreas. Mas aqui está o
detalhe crucial. Para que isso funcione,
os íons de zinco precisam estar
disponíveis localmente na região da
faringe e da nasofaringe, onde o vírus
está se multiplicando. E é por isso que
pasilhas são diferentes cápsulas. Quando
você dissolve uma pastilha de zinco
lentamente na boca, os íons são
liberados gradualmente e ficam em
contato com a mucosa faríja. Quando você
engole uma cápsula, o zinco vai direto
pro estômago e é absorvido
sistemicamente sem esse efeito local
antiviral. A metaálise de Hemilá focou
exclusivamente em estudos com pastilhas
por esse motivo. Agora, sobre a dose,
por que 75 mg é o corte mágico? Porque
nos estudos que usaram doses abaixo
disso, simplesmente não houve efeito.
Cinco ensaios com doses baixas, menores
que 75 mg por dia, uniformemente não
encontraram benefício na duração do
resfriado. Já os estudos com doses entre
80 e 92 mg por dia encontraram redução
de 33% da duração e os estudos com doses
ainda mais altas de 192 a 207 mg
encontraram efeito de 35% praticamente
igual. Ou seja, doses acima de 100 mg
por dia não parece oferecer benefício
adicional. O ponto ideal parece estar
entre 75 e 100 mg de zinco alimentar por
dia. E aqui entra um ponto que confunde
muita gente, acetato de zinco versus
gluconato de zinco. Você vai encontrar
opiniões fortes na internet sobre qual
forma melhor. A metanálise de 2017
comparou diretamente as duas e nos três
estudos com acetato de zinco, a redução
média foi de 40%. Nos quatro estudos com
gluconato foi de 28%. Parece uma
diferença grande, não é? Mas
estatisticamente falando, essa diferença
de 12 pontos percentuais
significativa. O intervalo de confiança
incluiu zero. Então, a conclusão dos
pesquisadores foi clara: pastilhas de
gluconato de zinco adequadamente
formuladas podem ser tão eficazes quanto
as de acetato. O que realmente importa é
que a pastilha libere íons desincuíveis
na boca. Algumas formulações de
gluconato contém aditivos como ácido
cítrico ou tartárico que quelam os íos
de zinco impedindo ação. Então, mais do
que a forma do sal, o que você precisa
verificar é se a formulação permite a
liberação adequada de zinco. Agora,
sobre o timing, quando começar, essa é
talvez a informação mais importante,
mais ignorada. análise de dados
individuais mostrou que o efeito do
zinco foi consistente, independentemente
de alergia, tabagismo, severidade
inicial do resfriado, idade, sexo ou
etnia. Mais um fator que aparece
repetidamente na literatura é o tempo de
início tratamento. Os estudos que
mostraram o benefício instruíram os
participantes a começar as partilhas nas
primeiras 24 horas após o início dos
sintomas. Quanto mais cedo você começa,
maior é a chance de você reduzir
significativamente a duração. Esperar
dois ou três dias para ver se o
resfriado vai piorar antes de agir,
provavelmente vai reduzir ou eliminar o
benefício. E quanto tempo você vai usar?
Os estudos tipicamente mantiveram o
tratamento por cerca de uma semana ou
até a resolução dos sintomas. Não
estamos falando de suplementação
crônica. É uma intervenção aguda de
curta duração iniciada ao primeiro sinal
de garganta arranhando ou nariz
escorrendo. A revisão CREN de 2024, que
é considerado padrão ouro em síntese de
evidências, incluiu 34 estudos e
concluiu que o zinco pode reduzir a
duração dos sintomas de resfriado quando
usado para tratamento com uma diferença
média cerca de 2,4 dias a menos. No
entanto, classificou a certeza de
evidência como baixa moderada,
principalmente devido à heterogeneidade
entre os estudos e variações nas
formulações testadas. Então, os autores
pediram mais pesquisas para determinar o
tipo exato de zinco, a dose e a duração
ideais. Jáemila e Chaler, em uma crítica
publicada na Frontiers Medicine em 2024
argumentaram que a revisão de CRIN
subestimou a eficácia ao misturar
estudos com formulações inadequadas e
doses baixas. Quando eles reanalisaram
apenas os estudos com formulações
apropriadas e doses acima de 75 mg,
encontraram uma redução de 37% na
duração do resfriado com valor de p
estatístico de 10 elevado-9.
uma evidência muito forte, estaticamente
falando. Então, como usar isso na
prática? Primeiro, tenha pastilhas de
zinco em casa antes de precisar delas.
Quando os sintomas começarem, inicie de
forma imediata. A dose alv é entre 75 a
100 mg de zinco elementar por dia. Isso
geralmente significa dissolver uma
pastilha de 15 a 25 mg a cada duas ou 3
horas enquanto você tiver acordado. Você
pode aproveitar e associar isso à
vitamina C também na dose de 500 mg a 1
g a cada poucas horas. Então mantenha
por cerca de 5 a 7 dias ou até os
sintomas desaparecerem. Não engula a
pastilha inteira. Deixe dissolver
lentamente na boca. Sobre os efeitos
colaterais, os mais comuns são gosto
metálico desagradável na boca e
ocasionalmente náusea. Nos estudos,
esses efeitos foram geralmente leves e
não levaram à descontinuação do
tratamento. A metaálise da CCRIN
encontrou um risco relativo de 1,34
para efeitos adversos não sérios com
zinco comparado ao placebo no
tratamento, principalmente relacionados
ao sabor. Nenhum estudo de tratamento
reportou efeitos adversos sérios. Uma
observação importante, existe uma
diferença entre pastiles de zinco para
resfriado e sprays nasais de zinco. Os
sprays nasais de zinco foram associados
em alguns casos à perda permanente
defato e a FDA americano e a FDA
americana emitiu alerta sobre eles. As
pastilhas orais não t esse risco, OK?
Então, fique com as pastilhas. E por que
isso funciona melhor em algumas pessoas
do que em outras? Os pesquisadores
analisaram vários fatores. Análise dados
individuais não encontrou modificação de
efeito por alergia, tabagismo,
severidade inicial, idade, sexo ou
etnia. Isso sugere que o benefício é
bastante consistente entre diferentes
grupos de pessoas. Então, claro, existe
variabilidade individual na resposta a
qualquer tratamento, mas as
características básicas do paciente não
parece ser preditoras importantes de
quem vai ou não vai responder ao zinco.
Então, para resumir de uma forma bem
direta, resfriado vai atrapalhar o seu
sono, seu trabalho, puxar sua imunidade
para baixo no ciclo de estresse que
ninguém precisa. Então, a estratégia
baseada em evidências é simples.
Pastilhas de zinco em dose diária entre
75 e 100 mg de zinco alimentar iniciadas
nas primeiras 24 horas de sintomas por
poucos dias. Eu associarei com vitamina
C também. A metaanálise mais rigorosa
mostra 33% menos dias doente. Em análise
subgrupo, 70% das pessoas recuperadas em
5 dias contra 27% do placebo. Então não
é mágica, é farmacologia básica dos ios
de zinco interferindo com a replicação
viral na mucosa farinja. Agora saia do
vídeo se você gosta de ficar no
superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
Conselho de Medicina me limitam a que eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens e
omitir protocolos controversos. Sobre o
zinco, por exemplo, eu não posso falar
abertamente sobre as doses que eu uso em
caso de infecções recorrentes, a
combinação com quecetina para
potencializar a entrada do zinco nas
células ou os protocolos de zinco
ionóforo que ganharam atenção durante a
pandemia. Na comunidade fechada não
temos esse filtro. Eu compartilho os
exatos protocolos que eu uso na minha
clínica, incluindo o protocolo completo
de suplementação para imunidade com
doses precisas, time de cada nutriente e
as combinações cinéticas que realmente
funcionam. Talvez casos de reversão que
parecem possíveis, combinações offlab
que funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. Então
é basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Nós temos
lives semanais respondendo perguntas,
PDF com 47 protocolos exclusivos, grupo
no WhatsApp. Então, se você quer a visão
funcional real sem simplificação para as
massas, clique em seja membro. Não é
para curiosos, é para quem quer
resultados. Agora, se você quer ainda
mais fundo, tem o nível dois. A cada
duas semanas, nós temos lives de imersão
total, 2 horas de duração, desse secando
artigos científicos, linha por linha,
como as metaanálises de Hemilá sobre
zinco e vitamina C, que a maioria dos
médicos ainda não conhece. Nós debatemos
controvérsias que ninguém ousa tocar,
revelamos os bastidores das pesquisas
que a indústria não quer que você
entenda. E tem mais, o seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna parte
visível dessa comunidade elite que está
reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará do meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Não é
só sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer ao
ciclo interno de quem está mudando o
jogo. Poucos têm essa coragem. Você tem?
Já que estamos falando de imunidade,
você precisa entender como a glutamina
pode ser a peça que tá faltando na sua
defesa, especialmente se você treina
pesado ou passa por período de estresse
intenso. Então assiste esse vídeo aqui
sobre glutamina, imunidade que vai
complementar perfeitamente o que você
aprendeu hoje. Agradecimentos especiais
aos nossos queridos membros dos estudos
avançados da comunidade fechada do
YouTube. Estrigo, Juliana Pontes e Ana
Medicina, Antônio Renato, Karim,
Lourdet, Carlos Roveri, Odonor Pinheiro,
Cíntia de Assis Oliveira, Adriane BMS,
Jorge Cabral, Marcelo Pimentel, Cláudia
Leitão, Alex Caldas, Ana Paula Vascular,
José Fortunato Mutinho, FS Machado RJ,
Soujo Cioli, Cristina Carol, Romana
Moraril, Estela Mar Silva Elô Terapias
Integrativas e Saúde Lã.